making his tenth start on the mound
today for the pirates is veteran lefty
tyler anderson who has struggled a bit
his last two starts but bob this guy
knows what he's doing
hesitation swinging a pop-up back of
first base
it'll be the second baseman adam frazier
ranging into right field he'll retire
and one out as contreras is gone
so one out and now anderson will face
chris bryant
in the air that one is drilled to center
way back going back is reynolds and gone
home run chris bryant a towering blast
to center field
and on number 11 the cubs jump on top it
is one to nothing k.b goes yard
bias took a wicked swing that was up
just high enough
and tyler anderson
strikes out david bodie
chris bryant the home run his 11th when
nothing comes it's the professor kyle
that sinker change up combo occasionally
will elevate a four seamer
reaching out and that one lifted out
towards left center where hat makes the
grab
and that ball is hammered to right but
right there is wisdom to make the catch
he hit it right on the button but right
at the right field
softly third base side boat he was in on
the grass and an easy one two three
inning for kyle hendricks eight pitches
the pirates go in order end of one
gets a strikeout there of patrick wisdom
and thankfully anderson misses yep that
attempt he goes right to the short stop
six three one two three and it's a
one-nothing cubs lead
you see hendricks decides not to attempt
through after that ball and soul guard
had it skip off as glove and look at
gonzales heads up
it's a double out of it
how about that that's a bouncer
[Applause]
they had a swing and a miss good
change-up struck him out
inning over first punch out of the day
for the professor
hendricks waits the pitch
right there strike three call with a
fast ball
anderson ready here comes
bouncer toward the middle that's a base
hit to center field contreras a sharp
single up the middle
that's his first hit since his injured
hand the other night in st louis still
amazed that he's even playing at this
point happily rizzo pending free agent
there's a swing and a miss he struck him
out 91 so he dialed it up
stealing second is contreras
and he makes it cubs lead one to nothing
in the third and the batter is javier
baez
baez hits it on the ground to third
gonzalez
[Applause]
this is so good
oh my goodness wow you gotta be kidding
me
you've gotta be stolen
you have got to be kidding me javi baez
keep going go go vicky you're invisible
elma go indeed
from second wilson contreras
rounded third and headed for the plate
and he scores i can't believe that yeah
it's it's just a routine out it's a
ground ball of the third and and javi
stops short of the bag because the
throat takes craig up the line all craig
has to do is turn around and just walk
over to first base and touch the bag
instead he keeps thinking i'm going to
tag him and literally almost walks him
all the way to home plate
and then it just gets ugly from there
because the flip to the catcher perez
behind the plate contreras dives in safe
now baez sprints to first and they start
throwing the ball all over the place
this is one of the craziest
little league type plays you'll ever see
in major league baseball
baez just kept running back toward the
plate
and stayed
in the rundown long enough for contreras
to score with a head first slide what i
loved was baez was there to
you know exalt and pump his fist as if
to say all right you made it safe hey
wait i can still run to first i'm still
safe
[Music]
in the air shallow center and it'll fall
for a hit and here he comes around third
to score
more hobby magic amazing
you are incredible
that hit him
it did
not wearing any type of protective
device on his arm
although what's happening here what is
happening here review this one do they
want to talk about it
this is going to prove to be a good
challenge by derrick shelton
[Music]
yeah month of may 115 out of 22. only
the padres have been better in the nl
david ross saying
that this team is gaining confidence
and
that one is well hit left field that one
back on its way god patrick wisdom his
first homer as a cub
and it's now four to nothing
allows patrick wisdom to swing the bat
and wisdom delivers the long ball good
for you patrick wisdom
brian reynolds bounced
to third his first time up and hits a
high fly ball deep right center field
wisdom is back
anchored down
and bounce tour of the water reynolds is
fifth the pirates on the board
four to one
430 foot blast oh there's a drive to
right field did he get enough of it
polanco with a cup of coffee
back-to-back clear the deck
a couple of cannonballs polanco's fifth
is now 4-2 hendricks made a mistake with
that pitch
polanco made him pay
a swing and a miss and a strikeout
52nd overall
back in 2012. that one to right polanco
back he's gonna have to play it off the
wall collects it wisdom towards second
and he's in with a double habit dave
patrick wisdom
a two out two base hit
and the inning continues here in the
sixth
intelligent pitching for sure from both
sides yeah they both don't know how to
pitch
catch me can you stick around for
another half inning you're too busy well
yeah i got nothing else to do in my life
and a swing and a miss struck him out
two into the count the pitch
swing and a miss struck him out
and hendricks picked a good time for the
punch-out
here's the one
perez sends one toward right center
field back is hap at the wall it's a
one-run game clear the deck with a
cannonball perez hits his third maybe
we're gonna win this one
on the comeback trail
via the long ball
that one off the leg of the pitcher
trickles to third and it'll be an
infield single
fly ball to the left and gammel with a
great
diving catch
number two nice read off the bat make
that dive possible
what a play by ben gamel it's 3-2 so
there's no reason to hold him on
and the bases are now loaded
and does eric gonzalez see winkler or
tupera david ross's decision eric
gonzalez coming to the plate deal one
that's hit on the ground to short baez
to soul guard and they get out of it
that's lined into left and a base hit
towards the corner eric sogart on the go
picking it up is gammel and they'll hold
up sogo
on the ground and newman
goes to first run scores throw to third
out there and that's the inning but they
pick up a run
it's 5-3 so some insurance for the cubs
as chris bryant knocks in the run
field two
chopped on the ground that's out to
shore
ball game cubs win
they sweep the pirates
and they are tied for first place
ryan tapara and the cubs pick up the win
and the first series sweep at pnc
since 2016